how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder i am your host warren
thompson this is my cat rocket raccoon
who yes is hiding under a box of
lightsabers today we have some really
really big news as it's been reported
that a solo hulk film is happening in
the mcu it's already in pre-production
and going to be starting very very soon
and not just any hulk film
a world war hulk film which i know a lot
of fans are really really excited to see
and i know what some of you may be
thinking how exactly is marvel studios
going to do a solo hook film when
universal supposedly has the rights to
solo hope films well i'm going to
explain everything you need to know
about what is happening with this
project in this video including what we
know the plot to be because as we know
marvel studios just doesn't take comic
stories put them into movie form and
that's that of course they always change
them so lots to talk about in this video
and be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on the mcu and also we are
giving away a really cool spider-man
action figure to one of our subscribers
the giveaway ends at the end of this
month all you have to do to enter the
giveaway is subscribe to my channel and
subscribe to my other channel that chris
runs cosmic culture we'll put the link
in the description and in the pin
comments down below now world war hulk
is something that i don't think fans
thought we were going to be getting
anytime soon but yesterday the gww.com
reported world war hulk film slated to
begin production in
2022 and before we go any further let's
dive into their initial report which
says buckle up hulk fans she-hulk isn't
the only hulk related content coming in
the next few years the gw has learned
that a hulk movie is on the way and it's
currently being called world war hulk
yes we are finally having a new solo
hulk film in active development at
marvel studios and we were told it's
currently slated to start production in
late 2022 likely following the events of
the upcoming she-hulk series on disney
plus now they go on to say that this is
coming from one of their personal
sources who has been right about many
things in the past and i can attest to
this as well because we've seen reports
from the gw come true so there is big
credibility here now it also isn't that
big of a surprise if you consider the
shang chi and the legend of the 10 rings
post credits scene i won't mention what
was in it but if you've seen it you know
not to mention mark ruffalo is confirmed
to be returning as the hulk in she-hulk
there is clearly a lot more story to
tell again especially if you consider
the xiang chi post-credits scene now in
the comics bruce banner is cousins with
jennifer walters aka she-hulk he is
actually the reason why she becomes
she-hulk she gets in a devastating
accident and bruce banner has a blood
transfusion with his cousin which ends
up saving her life but he ends up
transferring some of that gamma
radiation over whatever the heck is in
his blood and she ends up becoming
she-hulk so it looks like we're
definitely going to be seeing some type
of iteration of that story and if we
think about it mark ruffalo has recently
talked about how he has a lot of ideas
left for the hulk and if we think about
one of the most insanely cool hulk
stories there is well it's hard to beat
world war hulk it's an insanely cool
storyline but let's talk about the
rights to the hulk and how marvel
studios is able to make a solo hulk film
when for the longest time universal
owned the rights to do a solo hulk film
this is why the hulk had to appear in
other films with other heroes like thor
ragnarok it was really a thor slash hulk
film however in 2020 there were reports
going around that universal and marvel
studios had reached an agreement and the
rights to the hulk solo film properties
have gone back to marvel studios the
report actually said that the rights to
the hulk and neymar which universal also
owned went back to marvel studios now
recently it's been pretty much confirmed
that tina kuerta has been cast to play
namor in black panther 2 wakanda forever
and although marvel studios hasn't come
out and said it yet it's pretty much
been confirmed by some major trades and
insiders so if the rights to namor have
went back then we could probably assume
that the rights to the hulk are back as
well since they're both coming from the
same place the hulk is a huge character
to marvel studios so it would make sense
that they would kind of do whatever it
would take to get the rights to a hulk
solo phone back so they could proceed
and it looks like they have done so and
it looks like the story that they're
going to go with is the world war hulk
story which is very very interesting
because this story has connections to
the illuminati in marvel comics and the
illuminati is reportedly appearing in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness now here's what you need to know
about world war hulk and the events
leading up to it the storyline known as
planet hulk both involve the illuminati
now what happens in planet hulk is a
gamma bomb causes the hulk to lose
control and attack las vegas and the
illuminati get together and they decide
that the hulk is too dangerous and they
need to take him off earth so they trick
him they tell him that they're going to
send him into earth's orbit so he can
destroy a rogue satellite however once
he's in orbit they shoot him off into
space now originally they plan to send
him to a peaceful planet but the ship
actually ends up going through a
wormhole he ends up landing on the
planet zakar which is kind of what we
saw in thor ragnarok in fact that part
on sakhar of thor ragnarok was based off
of the planet hulk storyline the hulk
actually gets an obedience disc which we
saw in thor ragnarok and the red king
forces him to be a gladiator now
eventually what would happen is that the
silver surfer would end up freeing all
of the gladiators from their obedience
diss and eventually the hulk kills the
red king with the help of his former
lieutenant caira the hulk would end up
becoming the king of sakhar and he would
end up marrying the lieutenant kiera and
she ends up becoming pregnant with their
child however unfortunately the ship
that the illuminati sent hulk into space
in ends up blowing up and kills kyra and
the hulk's child from there the hulk and
his war bound leaves a car and they go
to earth and from there we get the world
war hulk storyline now once he gets to
earth it's absolutely insane he goes
through like all of the heroes he
defeats black bold he defeats iron man
and destroys stark tower he goes to the
home of the x-men and defeats many of
them and he even fights the juggernaut
he would go on to fight the new avengers
the mighty avengers the fantastic four
black panther storm ghost rider and he
would defeat all of them and then he
would put obedience diss on them he even
goes on to fight doctor strange in which
doctor strange had fused with the demon
zomb just to take on the hulk but the
hulk beats him he even defeats the us
army in thunderbolt ross now he takes
all of the people prisoners and he takes
over madison square garden and he turns
this into a gladiator arena with the
plan of forcing all of the people to
fight each other to the death now
eventually the hulk and century would
fight and they leveled the entire city
they fight till they're both passed out
while the hulk is now in bruce banner
form meek informs the hulk that he
actually let the explosion happen
because he wanted the hulk to continue
to destroy everything this causes him to
go into extreme rage and he's radiating
energy that threatens to destroy earth
so he tells tony stark to activate a
special satellite weapon that leaves him
unconscious and in his bruce banner form
in which then shield takes him to prison
so as you can see this is an incredible
story and i do not do it justice because
it actually is quite long and i'm just
giving you a rundown i suggest checking
out both of these stories planet hulk
and world war hulk but like i said in
the beginning we know that marvel does
not just adapt the comic story for story
but can you imagine if in a world war
hulk movie he fought all of the heroes
and defeated them and basically made
them his puppets this is the hulk that
everybody has been waiting for we don't
want the smart hulk professor hulk
whatever you want to call it we want a
hulk who is just absolutely insane and
filled with rage and it's looking like
we are going to be getting some type of
that storyline the cool thing about
world war hulk is that he has so much
gamma radiation in him he's a really
really strong hulk and there's
definitely lots of ways that they could
take this in the mcu they can even say
that all of the energy from snapping
could have caused the hulk to maybe get
stronger perhaps that's how his arm
actually ends up healing yes it damaged
him at first but maybe over time it
affects him in a rather good way until
eventually he loses control either way i
am definitely here for whatever
iteration of a world war hulk story that
they want to tell but let me know how
you think that this story should go in
the mcu in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you